yesterday will likely be seen as a
turning point for the better last night
a short video appeared on the Internet
it was not produced by epidemiologists
it was shot on an iPhone in a kitchen by
a guy who runs a sports site but in 3
minutes and 37 seconds Dave Portnoy a
barstool sports laid out perhaps better
than anyone ever has the absurdity of
our current lockdown strategy here's
part of it
what's going on when did this become
flat my curve flattened the curve
flattening curve - we have to find a
cure or everyone's gonna die find it
care who says we're gonna find a cure
people been mentally preparing we're
doing what you asked we've done exactly
what you said now you're changing the
rules in barely 24 hours that clip what
you should look up if you haven't
already before it's pulled down
has been if you'd close to five million
times we're happy to have Dave Portnoy
joined us tonight so Dave what inspired
you to do this to make this video well I
mean if we're being honest Tucker I've
been in the stock market the stock
market tanked and a lot of it tanked
basically on you know
ouchy going before the Senate and
talking about the future in the LA mayor
saying he was gonna walk the city down
until they found the cure and I'm in New
York City so I'm in the heart of it and
you know I've been inside I haven't gone
outside in months and to me New York
City is kind of at you know corner
fatigue like the rest of the country but
everybody is trying to do their best
which is yet inside social distance flat
the curve flatten the curve that kind of
the combination of the hearings in the
or the Senate and the LA mayor that to
me came out of left field it's like I
hadn't been hearing that we were all I
felt like there was a collective
positive vibe in the country especially
New York we're getting close we're
getting close we're getting ready sir
you know every every update seemed more
positive there are open beds people were
you know you weren't hearing the horror
stories necessarily anymore and then
this comes out of left field like we're
no closer than we were two months ago it
seemed and at this point
you know I started bar stool I start bar
so 17 years ago and the main gist of
that rent and it really shouldn't be
political it should be
it should be right I don't think it is
political exactly but if you gave me the
choice it took me ten years a decade
working almost 24-hour days no
exaggeration to turn the corner and
become successful if Corona hit at that
moment I would been out of business and
everything that works the ten years gone
flushed down the toilet at the very
least and Barcelona make it so thank God
I'm wearing a good shake but a lot of
people aren't and at the very least they
should have the auction this wrist fine
I don't know what to believe there's so
many you know you hit different things
wear a mask don't wear masks yeah I
think most doctors vow she'll be even
like there's a new disease we don't know
we don't know what we're dealing with
fine give me the choice then let me go
outside and risk potentially getting
sick or do I want to ruin my business
because it was me I would rather die
from Corona then have to start over work
a nine-to-five fight how are you gonna
get a job I didn't put money on your
family's table when the economy is gonna
be gone so that was really the rant it's
at the very least I feel bad for people
who aren't given the choice
what's worse losing my business my
livelihood or the chance of getting this
disease which we honestly know so little
about I feel like we're no closer that's
what that's what I think the problem is
so you've been attacked as some kind of
science denier for putting this on the
internet pretty bit early I perform sort
of a whole piece about how you're wrong
but you've taken this seriously from the
beginning you just said you've been
endorsed for months it's not like you've
denied the reality of the disease Tucker
a week ago I said everybody I did the
same exact rant except it was about
masks and this is a lot of people on on
I guess the right would describe it hey
everybody we're maps you know why
because if there's a point zero zero
zero zero one percent chance that
somehow helps and gets people back to
work then throw it on there's nothing to
lose so I've been on both sides I'm not
trying to make you pull up and by the
way the Forbes guy I I haven't seen the
article
he sent me an email five minutes before
I came on and said basically everything
you said was garbage do you want to
defend yourself but apparently already
went to print so yeah it went to print
our scan code it's kind of the way it
works sorry about that
NASCAR apparently is going back online
on Sunday I think Darlington maybe yo ha
my know your NASCAR fan do you think
other professional sports will soon come
back should they yeah it sounds like
they are I mean hold up and baseball
sounds more about the money side of it
but you know the NFL I think they will
and you know I've had my differences
with Roger Goodell even though I know if
you heard I am gonna spend a Monday
Night Football in his basement with them
but you know submitting yeah yeah Roger
Goodell he doesn't care about anything
he may be the guy that gets it back in
the streets huh well that's probably
good news and and finally like what's
your plan now the you but you've been
holed up you've expressed your
frustration you think the policies are
stupid which they are how are you gonna
live going forward I mean again this
isn't the crazy thing is this isn't
about me personally bars will be fine I
feel bad walking around the city and all
these restaurants that you're starting
to see you know signs and say we're not
coming back and the crazy thing is if
you go for a walk on the Hudson River
like today when it's 75 there's tons of
people outside so the policies aren't
necessarily been keeping people inside
is just keeping businesses closed and by
the way if Florida's open in New York's
close guess what I'm going to Florida
and then I'm coming back to New York and
lots of people are gonna do that so the
whole thing isn't gonna work the
policies are flawed regardless of how
you look at it if not everyone's working
together a lot of people aren't coming
back to New York and that's I don't know
if they get that yet that's the sad
thing Dave Portnoy thanks so much for
this you look great for a man who's been
in quarantine appreciate you I still got
the purple sweat pants on that's the
must be pretty rank at this point good
to see ya